Hey Youtubers! It's Charlie. So we just got some news about Kevan Lannister
in Game of Thrones Season 5
So I thought I'd do a history video for him
There's also a new wildling character that they revealed
it's gonna be at Hardhome. I'll explain who that is
We saw him on the trailer briefly.
I know what are you guys are asking
about the George RR Martin-initialed
Game of Throne's draft
so I'll try to explain that to you. It's really
just like a a simpler version of what he
ended up doing
First things first though: Kevan
Lannister. Okay, so here we go.. just careful
for spoilers
through Season 4 on the show. So Kevan Lannister has only appeared in Seasons 1
and 2 of Game of Thrones so far, of the TV series. The reason why people think he's
going to be in Season 5
is because the actor that plays him was
seen on set near the end of their
production cycle.
He has a really big part in Feast for
Crows and Dance with Dragons.
If you have read those books, just please
use spoiler tags in the comments if you wanna
comment about him.
I think the show will do his book plot
but they'll only do the big stuff
We just won't see him on screen all the time. That's one of the downfalls of the show
it has to pick and choose the characters
that it focuses on see you lose a lot of
the really small moments from the side
characters
The fun part is this Kevan's transition
from a background character to a main
character almost
Although I don't know if the show's gonna
depict him that way. After Tywin's
death in Season 4
He's the next Lannister in line aside
from Tywin's children
to take over Casterly Rock. Technically the succession would flow to Jaime, but since
he's a White Cloak,
he can't inherit property, nor does it seem
like he wants to
and Cersei's a woman so she's also out of the running. Too bad they weren't born in
Dorne
Dorne tends to honor its women, much
more than the rest of Westeros
Think of it as being very progressive,
King's Landing - not so much
Kevan is also Lancel's father. Remember
the last time we saw him
he was giving it to Cersei. Kevan is a lot
like Tywin Lannister
very practical, very driven. During the
war of the Five Kings, he was actually one of
Tywin's Chief Council
unlike Tywin and the rest of the
Lannisters, he actually still has quite a
bit of money
if you remember before he died, Tywin implied that the gold mines - the
Lannisters' gold mines were starting to
run dry
the crown is severely in debt, so Kevan
is just one of those people that could
potentially help them out
He's one of the closest family members. Who you gonna run to when you need money,
when you can run to your family first
even though Kevan has spent a lot of his
life in Tywin's shadow, I don't think that
he's super jealous
Where things sit right now, he's actually
in a pretty good place. As a family man,
he's a little more open about his
emotions than Tywin is.
When he finds out about the siege of King's Landing, he actually starts to freak out
a little bit about his son Lancel
It makes you think that scene at the
beginning of Season 4 when Jaime is
meeting with Tywin right after
getting his golden hand
When Tywin tries to give him the new
Valyrian sword that was reforged out of ice
to be fair though, I'm not sure Tywin being a more loving father to Jaime and Cersei
would have altered any of their weird twincest choices or what followed
Tywin still probably would have tried to
marry Cersei to Robert Baratheon
Jaime still would've ended up in the White Cloaks. That's one of the things I like most
about Song of Ice and Fire
is that bad things happen to good and
bad characters
It doesn't matter if you're evil. I think
what's gonna be most interesting is the
see how all the characters are changed
based on the crazy stuff that happened
last season especially Tywin's death
in King's Landing
Does anybody else kinda wonder if they're
gonna dovetail Kevan's story with Jamie's
story in Season 5?
If they're changing Jamie's story
significantly from the books, if he's
going to a dramatically different place
does that mean the Kevan's story will also
tie in with that? It's definitely going to be
fun having a character in King's Landing that isn't gonna take shit from anyone
that's like the High Sparrow character -
characters that are just like
"This is bullcrap, I'm calling you on it." I was like how George RR Martin has these
ridiculous characters the go on these
big tirades, and then there's always someone that
will step in and call them on their
bullshit at some point
There's always some other character waiting to slap them to their senses
For those that have read book 5, yes I do
feel like a lot
of what Kevan does in book 5 is gonna
get cut out. If you haven't read it, don't worry
it's not a big deal, you're not gonna miss it.
It has a lot to do with the Young Griff storyline
Just some things to look forward to from Kevan: he has a lot of money, the ability to hire
mercenaries if he needs them,
to raise an army, which most other people
in Westeros don't have right now
and he's really quick to call people on
their bullshit. I'm really looking forward
to some unlikable characters being put in their place. So here's my big question for you guys:
even if you haven't read the books.
Kevan Lannister, Tywin's younger brother,
what do you want to see him do in Season
5? If you have read the books, feel
free to include a a book moment.
But just please use a spoiler tag. Just to explain that new Wilding character
supposedly his name is 'Loboda'. He'll be
one of the Wildling leaders at Hardhome
he's not specifically a character from the
books, but he might end up getting a lot
of the scenes with John Snow.
And just a comment on the George RR Martin-modified Game of Thrones story -
the info that was posted is just an initial
outline for the series. There are some
interesting differences. So vastly fewer storylines, mostly focusing on the Lannisters than the Starks.
A lot of the big stuff is still there, like
a lot of the same characters still
end up dying - Robert Baratheon,
Red Wedding stuff still happened. One of the big differences though, is the way
Danaerys got her dragons
Instead of being a wedding gift, she just
finds them during a Dothraki invasion that she leads
He also does a lot more with the battles.
There's like a lot more
attention paid to what happens during the battles.
I really think the original structure is
just more traditional fantasy, like what
you see for most fantasy books
Since they've been published, a lot of
people been really happy with the way
Martin has structured his story
just because it's been such a departure
from Tolkien. In any time someone writes a
new fantasy story, everyone always talks about how it looks like Lord of the Rings,
or some other familiar big series.
Martin's is a good example of something that is really different. So anytime
you have a friend who's looking to read
fantasy but doesn't like Lord of the Rings
and want something really different
Game of Thrones is the perfect example - or Song of Ice and Fire.
So as much as it turned into this big
sprawling thing and it's made it a lot
harder to get books out faster,
it's also made it that much better. I
think it has a lot to do with why the series is
so popular
One of the really cool detail is that Martin
talks about how he doesn't like to make outlines
So like, he doesn't like the plan his
stories out too much in advance
I feel like he does have a really good idea
where he wants the rest of the series to go
he knows that the big signpost that he
wants to get to, it's just like all the
side stories, all the lesser characters that he plans out while he's doing it
He's really good about posting sample
chapters, like Winds of Winter for instance
He posted a lot of sample bits of that
throughout the year, so he might update
that pretty soon. The last sample he
posted was for an Arianne Martell chapter.
So it's the new Game of Thrones video so I need to announce a new winner of the giveaway.
Congratulations to Edward Brock,
you can actually get your pick. You
can pick the Amazon gift card which is
a $20 Amazon gift card
or you can pick a copy of that Game of Thrones Telltale game.
Just be sure to message me on my channel for contact details, so I can get your email
Don't worry, I will do a new round of the giveaway whenever I do my Behind-the-Scenes video
For those asking about the Telltale game,
episode 2 was released this week
I am gonna do some gameplay videos on my game channel, so if you don't know where
that is, it's Charlie Streams - there's a
link in the description
I'm gonna try and stream on my Twitch channel on Saturday.
Okay so don't forget, this weekend I'll be posting my Game of Thrones Behind-the-Scenes video on Sunday,
after HBO airs the special on TV. Be sure to subscribe to get that. It'll feel like a
full-on episode. It won't be like the
7-minute special that they did last
year. It'll be way bigger than that. So while you guys wait for that
you can click here to watch the Season 5 trailer again
and you can click here to watch the Daredevil Netflix trailer.
It'll be like the closest we ever get to a Marvel HBO series.
It's gonna be pretty graphic - way more graphic than the stuff on ABC.
So thank you so much for watching! So let's all high-five. I'll see you guys this weekend!